[Música]
um dia todas bom dia não desculpa boa
noite a todas e todos é que a página é
bom como diretora de políticas públicas
e relações governamentais é de 99
eu participo de muitos eventos de
tecnologia de mobilidade de é de
transporte de modo geral ea primeira
pergunta que me fazem naquele momento
das perguntas é mais ainda quando é que
vai chegar carro rodou no brasil e carro
autônomo é eo rapper lupe quando chega e
eu sempre tive muita dificuldade e em
dar suas respostas e eu demorei bastante
pra pensar porque no fundo o que me vem
à cabeça eu trabalho com governo todo
dia é eu trabalho política pública todo
dia há quase 20 anos e quando vêem essas
perguntas pra mim na minha cabeça
aparecem essas imagens né é aos céus e
os voadores gente vivendo em cápsulas e
prédios de vidro é naves não espaciais
mas mais urbanas e eu não consigo
exatamente conectar com a realidade que
eu vivo a realidade das cidades
brasileiras e é muito difícil dessa
resposta eu acho que ao longo da dos
meus anos 99
é claro que é normal essa pergunta
porque a maior parte das empresas que
trabalha com tecnologia mobilidade estão
trabalhando se desenvolvendo carros
autônomos carros voadores e assim por
diante
mas no fundo eu quero pensar na
realidade brasileira né eu acho que a
minha resposta hoje que a tecnologia
pode fazer muito antes de chegar nessa
realidade o top cau distópica não sei eu
acho que eu não gostaria de viver nessas
cidades é eu acho que a gente tem um
caminho aí para trabalhar com tecnologia
mobilidade e cidades é que antes desse
momento né eu acho que só para ilustrar
um pouquinho onde a gente onde a gente
está e onde está a minha cabeça e quem
trabalha com política de mobilidade é te
conhece essa imagem eu não vou enfim não
é novidade isso isso é basicamente um
grupo de pessoas e um espaço que elas
usariam a usando diferentes modais
é nossa primeira foto a gente vê o
espaço que as bicicletas ocupa esse
mesmo grupo de pessoas usando bicicletas
a segunda o cada um dividida dirigindo
seu próprio carro é ea terceira se todos
estivessem dentro de um ônibus
e obviamente a gente vê esse espaço
maravilhoso na primeira terça foto e
falar poxa vida mas porque a gente não
tá aí né espaço sendo utilizada para
outras coisas talvez é parques de lazer
e assim por diante e no fundo a gente
vive nas nossas cidades a gente vive
essa foto do meio um monte de carro
enfileirado cada pessoa no seu carro é
os ônibus aí tentando a quem não tem
consegue ter carro tá apertado no ônibus
do transporte público tentando achar
algum lugar entre os carros todo mundo
tentando chegar a algum lugar e não
consegui chegar a lugar nenhum eu eu eu
sou de são paulo dá pra ver o nosso
ataque é e é uma diversão falar de
trânsito nem falar também que não tem
estacionamento dos carros
falta estacionamento é falta espaço com
os carros
mas falta mesmo entre 85 e 2013
em são paulo a área construída é
dedicada a estacionamento e
empreendimentos residenciais e
comerciais foi de 52% da área os 52 por
cento da área aos 30 que a cada 100
metros quadrados 52 são dedicados aos
carros não aos seres humanos é uma coisa
errada aí né e como é que a gente chegou
aí então acho que a gente tem coisas que
estão relacionadas à ikea não são
necessariamente relacionadas à
tecnologia
hoje por exemplo a maior parte das
cidades às legislações
dizem que os empreendimentos precisam
ter uma alma tanto tanto residenciais
quanto quanto quanto comerciais precisam
ter um número mínimo de vagas de garagem
isso não faz o menor sentido né eu acho
que deveria ter um número máximo de
vagas de garagem é repente em são paulo
é a feita semana passada a nova lei de
zoneamento entrega de flor e finalmente
estabelece estabeleceu um número máximo
de vagas de garagem que está sendo
discutido aqui em curitiba também em
outra cidade que a gente tem que mudar
esse paradigma é desincentivar o uso do
carro quando a gente facilita as coisas
ficam um pouco complicadas né
outro tipo de política porque que o
valor do estado por exemplo em curitiba
é menor do que o valor da passagem de
ônibus a gente está incentivando as
pessoas a usarem os carros não estou
falando só de curitiba aqui mas em são
paulo também tem uma nova licitação do
zona azul em que aumenta o número de
vagas aumenta o número de vagas usadas
nas ruas os carros pra lá pra encarar um
pouquinho o tamanho de tudo isso o
espaço ocupado a gente fez um estudo 99
é com dados públicos de belo horizonte é
de toda área pública usadas nas ruas
para estacionamento de carro
a gente está falando é equivalente a
mais de sessenta e cinco praças da
liberdade praça liberdade uma praça
conhecida em belo horizonte
só para se ter uma idéia no centro ser
equivalente a seis praças só das áreas
utilizadas para carro próprio
a suzano está falando você trabalhando
99 7 está dizendo que não é pra ter
carro não é atacar o próprio é não é pra
tocar o próprio o futuro das cidades é
aquele futuro das do disco de automóveis
e as nossas viagens são compartilhadas
estou falando de transporte público
estou falando de bicicleta estou falando
de patinete estou falando de carro senão
a gente não comporta tudo isso na cidade
pra a gente fez o estudo é com a afip da
usp é pra começar a medir o impacto do
compartilhamento na cidade
é o impacto do nosso serviço nas cidades
é só fizemos aí uma escala a cada um um
estádio de futebol médio equivale mais
ou menos mil vagas de carro né ea gente
fez esse estudo de impacto só com o
serviço de hoje a gente está falando de
a de que a gente diminuiu a demanda por
estacionamento porque as pessoas ou
deixaram de usar o carro próprio ou
pararam de comprar carro e diminuiu o
número de demanda por vaga na cidade de
são paulo e 78 mil vagas ou seja você
tem de oito estádios de futebol só com
que a gente tem hoje a gente fez algumas
simulações fosse bom
cito disse 10 por cento das viagens de
carros feitos por cá cada indivíduo no
seu carro próprio 10% só fossem
deixassem de ser feita desse jeito
fossem feitas com o compartilhamento
o que isso significaria para a cidade em
termos de demanda por estacionamento um
espaço público espaço poderia ser usado
pra n outras coisas pra parte para lazer
pra comércio para o hospital para a
escola
a gente está falando de 818 mil vagas
818 estádios de futebol é esse a gente
pensa já numa substituição dessas
viagens feitas por carro próprio de 50
por cento que passará assim a ser feitas
por compartilhamento
a gente está falando de 4 milhões 4
milhões e 600 mil vagas 46 mil estádios
quer dizer compartilhar é tudo bem
compartilhamento gente no mesmo carro
mas não só isso é imagine que um carro
que a gente usa que quem vem de carro
hoje todo mundo né é um jogo rápido
os carros estão parados lá fora não
sendo usados né é então que em 90 e 90
95% do tempo os carros estão parados
eles não estão sendo usados tem
utilidade nenhuma então ocupando espaço
na rua
então a gente está falando deste tipo de
compartilhamento e também
o uso intensivo de cada automóvel como é
que a gente faz as pessoas deixarem de
usar o carro não é porque é óbvio seria
ótimo é mais as pessoas querem conforto
as pessoas querem segurança as pessoas
querem previsibilidade e acho que tem
vários fatores aí mais uma das coisas
uma das provocações aqui é que a gente
tem que investir de fato é integração
entre os modais e aqui eu tô falando
assim em curitiba é um é sempre uma
referência em transporte e mobilidade e
agora acho que existe uma outra outro
passo a ser dado que a integração de
fato entre os diferentes as diferentes
formas de transporte é e aqui não estou
falando somente de é integração entre o
público eo público mas também entre o
público eo privado a lugares específicos
para em vez de ter vaga para
estacionamento poderia ter lugares
específicos de embarque e desembarque
para que as pessoas de repente pudessem
chegar a uma estação tubo certo é
poderia tipo de poder se poderiam chegar
mais facilmente poderiam pegar um
patinete estações em que poderia ter
esse tipo de troca mas também ter uma
integração é de meios de pagamento
porque não há
quando pensa em cidade é multimodal é e
as do futuro eu penso nesta imagem não
na imagem daqueles carros voadores todos
vocês que a gente chegue lá algum dia
mas o que está mais próximo da nossa
realidade é essa imagem é uma imagem que
tem mais mais fácil para a bicicleta
mais espaço para as pessoas estarem no
parque as crianças poderão brincar tem
mais espaço para o transporte público é
e sim para carros mais compartilhados
outro ponto importantíssimo da
integração de investimento da integração
modal né entre os diferentes meios de
transporte
é eu acho que o que a gente investe mais
é na forma na integração desses dos
transportes a gente está investindo na
integração da cidade e diminuindo as
desigualdades também quem sofre mais
com a falta dessa integração é quem está
na periferia e os pés e esse gráfico
aqui que eu queria mostrar pra vocês é
acho que o tão pequenininho uma fonte
mas é basicamente como as mulheres e os
homens se deslocam pela cidade é esses
dados aqui são da da região
metropolitana de são paulo mas não é
muito diferente para as esperanças para
grandes capitais do brasil
os homens eles têm a primeiro antes de
tudo e se esse bloquinho do meio aí é
como as pessoas se low cost diz que 30%
das pessoas se locomovem a pé disse
trinta por cento das viagens são feitas
a pé nas grandes cidades brasileiras
agora tem também uma diferença entre as
mulheres e os homens a grande diferença
aqui é que os homens se locomovem mais
se transportam mais por carro próprio
que é esse é 36,5 por cento das viagens
feitas por pelos homens é feita através
do carro pronto
no caso das mulheres e 25,2
isso acontece por n motivos motivos
históricos sociais machistas dúvida é de
acesso ao carro de posse ao carro as
mulheres têm menos posses é o carro tem
uma outra questão é muito relevante da
forma como as mulheres se locomovem
velocidade é as mulheres hoje ainda
assim são muito mais responsáveis por
levar os filhos à escola é os filhos ao
médico fazer supermercado então
raramente esse trajeto da mulher é da
casa para o trabalho e do trabalho para
casa da casa para o estudo do estudo pra
casa como é da maioria dos homens
quando a gente fala integração modal na
verdade a gente está diminuindo se essa
distância entre os homens as mulheres ea
forma como elas é essa as mulheres
acessam a cidade e conseguem fazer as
suas atividades trazendo um pouco de
dados dada a 99 sobre integração e algo
que tá muito sendo falado nas cidades é
mas isso já está acontecendo é o que é
que o que é importante dizer aqui é que
esse tipo de integração de
compartilhamento já está sendo feito é
aproximadamente 63% das viagens feitas
99 é feita por mulheres ou seja ela já
estão fazendo esse tipo de integração
porque existe uma demanda existe uma
necessidade elas não tenham acesso ao
carro mas elas conseguem fazer esse tipo
de integração através do
compartilhamento de carros por
aplicativo é esses dados aqui são muito
interessantes eles são de são paulo e
rio
é o que eles mostram aqui o eixo
horizontal ele mostra os horários do dia
e e aqui é são as corridas que tem 80 em
destino numa estação de metrô em são
paulo no rio e vocês podem ver que tem
um pico aqui entre as 7 e 8 da manhã em
são paulo acho que o dia começa um pouco
mais cedo a laranja é mas no fundo o que
está dizendo aqui o sinte que as pessoas
estão chegando estão usando o
compartilhamento de automóvel ou seja
várias pessoas usando o mesmo carro
também pra chegar no metrô pra poder no
trabalho é a mesma coisa acontece no
final do dia a gente vê que tem muitas
chamadas nas estações de metrô em são
paulo e rio para sair do metrô ou seja
para chegar em casa e fazer a última
milha essa última perna só e tomando um
pouquinho o começo então a gente está
pensando aqui em tecnologia a gente tem
falado bastante hoje nessa tecnologia é
a relação com 15 as nossas relações de
trabalho na cidade é e quando penso na
cidade do futuro é tem muita coisa
envolvida que vai além da tecnologia
tecnologia pode ajudar a gente a gente
já está vendo a gente vê alguns dados
aqui que a gente pode reduzir o número
de demanda por vagas
a gente pode aumentar acesso das pessoas
à cidade
a gente pode integrar os modais integrar
mobilidade torná lo mais fácil mas tudo
isso depende muito também de política
pública isso não é tão difícil isso não
é necessário é a gente não precisa
esperar o carro voador
a gente não precisa esperar o carro
autônomo para fazer a gente
pode fazer junto é então pra mim essa
imagem está distante ainda a gente pode
fazer isso aqui acontecer muito mais
fácil a gente pode dar mais espaço para
as pessoas é e as pessoas têm mais
acesso poderem ler um livro na calçada
até essa cidade e isso independe tanto
das nesses novos avanços de grandes
tecnologias e que pesquisas não
necessariamente precisam chegar tão
rápido assim pra gente ter uma grande
cidade grandes cidades no brasil então a
notícia boa que eu tenho pra dar é que
isso já está acontecendo e 99 já tem
diversas conversas com as principais
prefeituras inclusive com aqui em
curitiba
e eu acho que quando a gente pensa em
cidade do futuro em vez de pensarem
cidade inteligente intelligent lembra
muito o sensor tecnologia coisas do tipo
e que são necessárias mas parece que é
só isso
é eu gosto de pensar a cidade sábias as
cidades e comunidades inteligentes né
com um foco mais uma pessoa pra ir pra
isso num país tão distante a gente só
precisa trabalhar junto e o que o que o
que me deixa muito feliz é que isso já
está acontecendo as prefeituras já estão
fazendo a gente já está trabalhando é
não só a gente mas essas grandes
empresas de tecnologia e mobilidade já
estão trabalhando com governos então é
eu só queria passar uma mensagem de
esperança e - de carros voadores e
autônomos a gente muito pra para ter uma
cidade feliz e compartilhada
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]